[Applause]
she's the most famous woman in Argentina
evaporon or Evita as people call her
and on Tuesday thousands took to the
streets to pay tribute on the 70th
anniversary of her death
Liliana Fernandez says Evita should
never be forgotten
she was a great woman someone who fought
for the poor Who challenged the powerful
that's why I'm here today because I want
to remember her
used her role as a first lady to secure
benefits for the working class founding
hospitals and orphanages she also helps
women get the vote she continues to be
revered by millions of people in this
country and has become the most powerful
symbol of the ruling pyranist party
evaporon died of cancer when she was
only 33 years old hundreds of thousands
of people attended her funeral her body
was embalmed and kept at the
headquarters of the most powerful labor
union in the country
when her husband Juan bidon was
overthrown in 1955. her remains were
kidnapped by members of the military
historians say it was a systematic
attempt to erase peronism a political
and social movement from Argentina
there are not many cases around the
world where the corpse was tortured she
was taken so people could not take
flowers to her tomb that shows the
importance of this woman who died so
young
Evita was finally brought back to
Argentina 20 years after her death and
is buried in a cemetery in Buenos Aires
it is here where hundreds of people have
queued for hours to visit her grave
we need to learn from her and always
carry her flag of what it meant to be a
woman during her era a flag of fight and
courage we need to continue her Legacy
to move forward and fight against the
powerful
evaporon inspired love but also hatred
among those who opposed parentism and
its attempts to empower the working
class those divisions continue to divide
Argentina today
but almost everyone here agrees that
Evita Changed History and helped give a
voice to those who had been ignored for
too long
there is Aires